NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Thanks for tuning
in to this special edition
of "Google Developers Live."
Today we're featuring Limor
Fried from Adafruit Industries
in celebration of Computer
Science Education Week.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Natalie
Villalobos, and I
will be your host for this
special edition of "Google
Developers Live."
Today, our guest is Limor Fried.
Limor is a graduate of MIT,
receiving her bachelor's
of science in electrical
engineering and computer
science and a master's
in engineering.
In 2005, she created her own
company, Adafruit Industries,
which is based in New York.
And they sell hackable
electronic kits.
In 2011, she was featured on
the cover of "Wired" magazine,
the first female
engineer-- ever, actually.
And in 2013,
"Entrepreneur" magazine
named her Entrepreneur
of the Year.
Thanks for joining us, Limor.
LIMOR FRIED: Thanks, Natalie.
I'm glad to be here.
Look at me, live engineer.
[INAUDIBLE]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
So most people--
LIMOR FRIED: [INAUDIBLE] live.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Most people
might not know you as Limor.
Some know you as ladyada.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about how you
received that name?
LIMOR FRIED: Yeah.
So when I used to break
into computers when
I was in high school,
you had a hacker handle.
And my handle was ladyada.
And I never got caught,
so that's kind of good.
And after I graduated
from school, and I'm like,
well, you know, I should
probably get a job
or start a company or something,
I decided to keep my handle.
So I still go by ladyada.
And the good news is
I've registered it
on all these websites for
so long that ladyada's it.
I can't really change now.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
So you've created the
Adafruit Learning System,
and you've also started
your own company.
So I want to hear
about that, too.
Can you tell us a
little bit more,
though, first about the
Adafruit Learning System?
LIMOR FRIED: Sure.
One of the things that
I do here at Adafruit
is I do a lot of engineering,
a lot of developing.
But when people buy stuff
from the Adafruit store,
they often tend to [? not
be ?] electrical engineers.
They don't have a lot of
experience with engineering.
They're just makers
or hackers or people
who maybe do
software, and they're
dabbling in doing some hardware.
And so they might
need a little bit
of help getting
started in how to use
these electronic parts
in their projects.
And so what we did is we
had this huge, vast amount
of documentation.
And we wanted to do
a really good job
in having that documentation
be easy to use, easy to find.
We wanted to integrate
photos and videos
and side by side and photo
notes and all the things that
make documentation
for electronics
really, really good.
I mean, a lot of times for
documentation for software,
it's just screenshots and text.
And that's OK, but with
hardware, you really
want to show videos
and wiring diagrams.
And so we developed
our own web application
that runs on the
Adafruit servers
called the Learning System.
And it's kind of
like bootstrap.py.
And what it does is it
allows us to do back
end design integration
with our store
so that, for example,
if a tutorial uses
a microscope or an
Arduino or a Raspberry Pi,
those will get
automatically tied together.
And so people can find the
tutorials really easily.
They can just go
through our shop
and say, well, I've got this
component or this component.
What projects could
I build with it?
And the Learning System
will automatically
guide them through what
cool project they can make.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: That's super
awesome and sounds really easy.
So you have some wearable
technology projects as well.
And being at Google, we love
some wearable technology
projects, like Google Glass.
Can you tell us a little bit
about your favorite wearables
project and how we might
get started with one?
LIMOR FRIED: Sure.
I really like wearables.
I've been doing wearables
for a really long time.
I was at the wearables group
in the Media Lab many, many,
many years ago.
And we were working on
like strapping computers
to our bodies and stuff.
And that was kind of
fun, although really big
and kind of clunky.
The cool thing is that 10
years later, microcontrollers
and electronics and batteries
are so much better and smaller
that instead of having
to spend like $2,000
to build your own
strap-on computer,
you can actually do a lot of
electronics for less than $50.
We have the Adafruit
GEMMA, which
is our little microcontroller
platform specifically
for low-cost wearables,
and it's like $8.
So for $8 and a
couple of LEDs, you
can actually start making
integrated sensors, LEDs,
projects.
People like modifying
their shoes and their bags
because shoes and bags
have really stiff sides,
so it's really easy to
attach electronics to them.
And also, we wear
them every day.
And it's kind of cool to have
funky shoes or a funky handbag.
So one of my favorite
projects right now
is we have the Firewalker
sneakers, which
is reactive shoes that light
up when you walk or dance.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
So it's not like they're
spouting fire or anything
like that.
LIMOR FRIED: No, they
just look like you
are because when you walk,
the red LEDs flicker,
and they look like
little flames,
like they're coming
out of your feet.
So I wear them on Halloween,
and they're totally awesome.
We're seeing lots
of people build them
because they're dancers
or artists or actors,
and they want to have
something kind of cool and fun
on stage or during performances.
So that's really common.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's awesome, yeah.
I like the idea of how every
item that you own or wear
could potentially be a platform.
And so literally, your platform
could be your platform, ha ha.
LIMOR FRIED: That's right.
Platform shoes have
lots of space on them.
You can stuff tons of
electronics in there
because you have to
put the batteries.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah,
like some energy scavenging
to even maybe make
some local power
supplies to actually
make that work.
LIMOR FRIED: Yeah, sure.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So one other question
that I'm really interested in.
So a lot of times, we're
carrying these devices,
and we're maybe not thinking
how we can build on them
or how we can create
them ourselves.
So there seems to be this
disconnect between building
and consuming.
Can you tell us how we might get
more connected with our devices
by building on them or
your general thoughts
on that kind of era,
this era of our lives?
LIMOR FRIED: Sure.
I think that,
especially now, it's
hard to buy electronics
that are hackable,
unless you're actually
looking for that.
You used to be able to buy
a Commodore 64 or an Apple
IIGS that came with schematics.
And it's like, you want
to add a 40 column board?
Here's how you do it.
And there'd be parallel
ports and COM ports.
And even that stuff doesn't
appear on computers anymore.
There's really not
a lot of easy ways
to integrate electronics
into stuff like a tablet.
It's just a slab of
glass, basically.
Which is why I think stuff
like the Raspberry Pi
and Arduino is really great.
You can take the
kind of technologies
that have become low cost
because of tablets and cell
phones and laptops, but
then build your own computer
or build your own cell
phone, build your own camera.
And by doing that, you
actually learn a lot,
and you get to
customize it in ways
that maybe the companies
that are selling
you a $500 digital camera
or laptop or tablet
didn't think of.
So a lot of people take
these technologies,
like Arduino and Raspberry
Pi, and these sensors
and combine them together to
make something custom or cool
or something that is their
own, not just something
that they bought in a store.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah, even
better than what you could buy.
So different people have
different interests-- cycling,
painting, rowing-- I
don't know, a whole bunch
of different things.
So if I were a kid, and
I had these interests,
how might coding or picking up
an electronic hackable kit--
how can I implement
those interests
into these particular types
of practices or methodologies?
LIMOR FRIED: I think
everyone's got hobbies
that are really fun
and interesting.
One of the cool new
hobbies that I'm
seeing that's picking up a
lot of stuff with electronics
is cosplay and costuming.
So there's all these people
who love to make costumes.
Costuming is the most fun thing.
Everyone loves Halloween.
Everyone loves to dress up.
And we've got all these cool
LEDs and wearable electronics
that we can now
add to our costumes
to make them light up or
make sounds or effects
or make you move
more like a robot.
So I'm seeing a lot of
people add electronics
and making to whatever
hobby they already have.
Like I know people who
really like to cycle,
and so they make
their own cycling
computers or their
own light painting
rigs that attach to a bicycle.
People who like to rock climb
will make their own timers
or digital cameras that they
can attach to themselves
and take time lapses
while they're doing stuff.
All of this stuff is taking
off the shelf electronics,
combining it with
coding and engineering
to make what you do more fun.
I know kids who
skateboard, and then
they put LEDs on
their skateboards,
so when they do tricks, they
get these really cool light
effects.
This is stuff that
you can't even buy.
You have to make it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
there's a lot of different--
so when you think
of a programmer,
or maybe not when you
think of a programmer,
but when some people
it's someone who's
sitting behind a computer
and maybe is just typing and
not really having a lot of fun.
Maybe they're like hunched
back and-- I don't know.
It doesn't seem to be
a very glamorous image.
If you were to fill in a "Mad
Lib," a programmer is what?
LIMOR FRIED: For people who
do electronics engineering,
a programmer is really creative.
I also used to do
computer science,
and I used to sit
behind a screen and type
and write code in
Java, and I hated it.
It was so boring.
And I was just
compiling and deploying
and linking libraries.
And I was like, this sucks.
I actually was bored of
doing computer science
because it was just like, you're
sitting in a room all day.
And so that's why I got
into electrical engineering.
Electrical engineering,
you take all the skills
that you may learn in
computer science class,
but then you can
build stuff with it.
You get to show it
off to your friends.
You get to be really creative.
I mean, you can always make
really cool apps and games
and stuff with
software, but I really
think that-- I love just having
physical stuff that moves,
like robotics or light
painting, or making
your own computers or your
own sensors or wearables.
All that stuff is a way to
take programming and just
make it more fun.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
So we have a huge developer
audience that's watching.
What would you like
to share with them?
Right now, we have Computer
Science Education Week.
We're empowering
everyone to learn
how to code through the Hour
of Code campaign with code.org.
How might you activate, or how
can developers get involved,
or where should they start
first with their kids,
in getting them involved
in electrical engineering
or computer science?
LIMOR FRIED: Sure.
I think that it's
always great to start
with some basic
tutorials and stuff.
But after you get a little bit
of the hang of programming,
either with Basic or Scratch
or JavaScript or whatever,
pick up something like
an Arduino starter kit
or a Raspberry Pi and then
try integrating all that stuff
that you learn in
software with sensors.
Like try to make LEDs blink.
Or when you press
a button, something
happens, or make some music.
A lot of people like to
booby-trap their rooms.
That's a common project that
we see a lot of kids do.
Because they have
their own space,
and you want to modify it.
So they'll put PIR sensors
that can detect people
and magnetic sensors
that can detect movement,
and then they'll set up
a camera to take photos
to make sure their
parents aren't sneaking
into their rooms when
they're in class.
So that's a really
fun project that
uses code and sensors and
electrical engineering
all together, and a
lot of these projects
aren't even that difficult.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That sounds incredible.
I am really jealous of
the kids these days.
LIMOR FRIED: How do you know
that somebody at your home
isn't in your room right now,
going through your stuff?
You don't.
That's why you have to
build something like this.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
I love it.
Yeah, I just started picking up
some Nests, the Nest Protects.
And I love the way that
it interacts with me
in my home environment.
And so I would love
for our students
out there to be able to
create these types of things
for their own home,
like home automation.
Why don't you just
go and do that?
So thank you so
much for joining us.
We've learned so much today.
LIMOR FRIED: Awesome.
Thanks for having me, Natalie.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
And I guess before
we sign off, do you
want to tell us a little bit
about where you are right now?
What's behind you?
LIMOR FRIED: Sure.
Right now, I'm at
the Adafruit factory,
which is why it's kind of
loud and crazy over here.
And we're in the middle of
the busiest season, Christmas,
which is when a lot of parents
get stuff for their kids,
a lot of sisters
and brothers get
stuff for their
siblings, et cetera,
and people get stuff for their
parents or significant others.
So people are giving the
gift of learning electronics
this season, and so we're
really, really busy.
And that's why there's so
much stuff going on here.
But it's also really
exciting to have a factory
here in Manhattan.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, and you
make a lot of your
own components
that go into your kits.
You make them in house, right?
LIMOR FRIED: Yeah.
A lot of these
technologies, it's
not stuff that's necessarily
available to people
who just want to
play with sensors
or LEDs or other
electronic components.
So what we do is we make
breakout boards or design kits,
and we contact factories.
And we can purchase
large quantities
and get custom-made stuff,
like displays, made for us
and then provide
them to customers.
So we kind of get to
go to all the factories
that make cell
phones and say, hey,
we're not making a cell phone,
but give us all the stuff
that you can make
your own cell phone.
And that's what we have
in the Adafruit shop.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Beautiful.
Well, thank you so
much for sharing
your factory and
your time today.
I really appreciate it.
If you would like to learn
more about Limor and Adafruit
Industries, go to Adafruit
Industries-- or adafruit.com.
Right?
LIMOR FRIED: That's right.
Adafruit.com.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Cool.
Awesome.
Thank you so much, Limor.
LIMOR FRIED: OK, thanks.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Make sure to join
in on the fun at
csedweek.org, where
you can participate
in an Hour of Code
during Computer
Science Education Week.